Now's your turn to use
Alteryx to aggregate data.
You're going to work with
a file of Wyoming schools.
If you're not familiar with Wyoming,
it's a state in
the United States of America.
It's known for the beautiful Yellowstone
National Park, which is famous for
a geyser called Old Faithful,
that erupts with water in
the air every few hours.
Now that you have a feel for
where Wyoming is,
let's get back to the exercise.
Taking the Wyoming school's sample file,
found in the notes below the video,
summarize the school data by zip code.
And count the total school
enrollment by zip code.
And count the number of
schools in each zip code.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What is the total enrollment
in zip code 82009?